good morning John and good morning
YouTube I from the waist up at least I'm
dressed quite nicely and that's because
I'm here to troduce what I believe to be
the largest YouTube community inspired
event it's called the project for
awesome very basically the project for
awesome is a day in which the YouTube
community takes over YouTube in order to
discuss and promote the work of people
who are doing things because they
believe it is the right thing to do not
because they believe that it is the way
that they're going to make the most
amount of money in the world in English
we generally call that charity and so we
do our part one day out of the year
during this lovely holiday season to
promote charity here on YouTube and then
the day after will go back to singing
silly songs who you are kept doing cute
things and being generally profane and
alienating people's parents and so on
this year's project for awesome I am
officially announcing will be taking
place December 17th 2008 although this
will be organized out of the project for
awesome website which is a product for
awesome calm so there are two ways to
participate in the project for awesome
hopefully you will do both but maybe you
will just do one of the two first is to
make a project for awesome video the
steps for that include step 1 make a
video about your favorite charity I
could make a video about Toys for Tots
or the Nature Conservancy or Save Darfur
it doesn't matter
make a video as normal but a little bit
in there about your favorite charity and
why you think it's a great thing to give
this charity why you yourself give to
this charity why you hope more people
will give to this charity Oh make the
following image or variant of it and
your thumbnail for that video we'll talk
a little bit more about that soon 3 make
sure your tags at your video name
include the words project for awesome
and your charity for link to your
charities YouTube channel on the sidebar
if they don't have a youtube channel
then link to their website and 5 submit
your video to the front door awesome
using the submit your video link at the
top of the perfect for awesome combo
page the second way to participate is to
be a project for awesome supporter I'm a
proud member of the project for awesome
supporters and basically all you have to
do to be prompted for awesome supporter
is to sign up for the project for
awesome mailing list which is on the
sidebar of project for awesome calm the
perfect girls of mailing list of project
for awesome calm will only be used for
the profit for awesome you will never
get an email after December 20th they
promise so will never give your email
address to anyone else we will not use
it as underarm deodorant we will not
sell it to the highest bidder throughout
that is the prompt if your awesome the
project for awesome mailing list will
feature certain videos those videos will
be rated and commented and favored up
like crazy so that those videos will hit
the big lists like the most discussed
and that way more people will see those
videos and then by the end of the
project for us of all the videos are all
the big lists and a book - the videos
that are currently being watched on
YouTube and the most viewed videos on
YouTube will all be part of the same
project and you will be able to tell
because they'll all have similar titles
and similar thumbnails they'll be
everywhere and everyone will know that
YouTube is awesome
we have editable Photoshop and fireworks
files of the project for awesome comm so
you can check things around and make
things unique to yourself as long as you
can tell that it's still a project for
awesome video so basically like you can
do this we need to do this but don't do
this but you could do this and you could
do this or this but not this not this
now before I get in some of the details
about how to make your screenshots work
I would like to make a very special
announcement my brother and I who run
this channel together vlogbrothers have
both decided to put up $1,000 that we
will be donating to a project for
awesome charity because of the project
for awesome because it's not just about
talking about charities it's about
giving to charities we will decide this
based not only on the quality of the
charity but of the quality of the video
made about the charity so late in videos
about charities and maybe your charity
will get $1,000 from genre B whoo and if
anybody else wants to do a similar thing
where they award money we really
encourage you to do that I'm so excited
about seeing those screenshots spread
throughout all of all of the love okay
for people who are making project for
awesome videos we have to talk a little
bit about your thumbnails because there
have been some changes to the way that
you do business I think what some nailin
what's not the thumbnail so we've talked
with YouTube a little bit there are two
solutions to this problem one only works
if you're a partner if you are not a
partner what you need to do is make sure
that the middle ten seconds of your
video is just the image I have done a
lot of research off living sample videos
making sure that this works and it does
work if it's 10 seconds long and it's in
the middle of the video then YouTube
will make it the thumbnail for your
video so it's a three minute video it's
like the ten seconds from 125 to 135 and
that's all you need to do to get your
thumb never be project for awesome
worthy okay I gotta go bye